hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
april 5th 2021 what's going on how
are you how's it going with you
are you hanging in there are you a
reasonably
intelligent person just being inundated
with
the stupidity that is all of this
[ __ ] media that's coming at you now
it really is uh
it really is something to behold you
know i started my day today right i woke
up this morning
and i was laying in the bed you know
we got all our plumbing issues fixed but
now you know there's some plunger in the
back of the [ __ ] toilet it never ends
it never ends but you know i got uh
i got all new pipes in the house
i think so at least coming out of the
house it's all good
we called rodo rooter that's the name
and your money goes down the [ __ ]
drain but it continues out to the street
and heads on out i got a 20-year
guarantee
that i can get onto the [ __ ] dumper
and drop a [ __ ]
deuce and it's gonna go down the [ __ ]
street until i'm
72 right that's it
that's right in 20 years i'm gonna be
72. that's how quick
it goes it's crazy george carlin died at
71.
[ __ ] nuts what a privilege it would
be
to live a year longer than that great
man and still be dropping a deuce in my
[ __ ] bathroom and it actually goes
down the [ __ ] street that would be
great
because i'm the crazy old guy on my
block because i never leave it i got too
much money in this [ __ ] house now
um anyway
so i woke up right this morning to my
daughter telling me like the
uh you know i need because what happened
was the flapper
on the back of the toilet the guy
adjusted the [ __ ] chain
because not enough water was slowing
down or whatever and now the flapper's a
little bit off so the toilet's running
all night so i shut the [ __ ] thing
off
so she didn't have to listen to it right
and then she comes in says she needs to
use the bad tiger [ __ ] yo
i gotta go in there and then handle that
[ __ ] right i gotta handle all of that
[ __ ] and then i'm like it doesn't need a
new flapper it needs
it needs you adjusted the chain
and now the [ __ ] flapper's not
covering the hole
completely but then if you adjust it if
you adjust it back there's not enough
water coming down from the tank
to do what the [ __ ] it needs to do to
get everything going out to the [ __ ]
street that i just paid a zillion
[ __ ] dollars for
but you know that's the old me i don't
get i don't you know i flip out but then
i just say out loud a guy you know i
don't want to get mad about this
okay because i am a yoga douche now i've
done yoga four times in the last
i don't know say like 10 days
you know namaste how's it going i think
that's how you say hello
when you walk into it you say namaste in
the end you know what i mean you
appropriate a little bit of the culture
you know you do some some sort of
[ __ ] little prayer hand thing
you know acting like you're not a white
douche like me totally caught up in
capitalism
trying to think about the next thing
that you want to buy that you don't
really [ __ ] need
you don't really [ __ ] need and you
might be asking yourself bill bill bill
let me let me let me let me
you probably have a lot of questions
what's the what's the latest thing that
you want that you don't need oh i'm
gonna tell you i found my dream [ __ ]
my latest dream car you know
i grew up playing with tonka trucks i've
always loved trucks my first car was a
truck
um first a car first automobile
sorry didn't mean to freak people out
that was [ __ ] on a pot cookie right
now how's your car a truck man
doesn't make sense it's like that old
joke the door is a jar
how's the door in jar man who used to
have that joke
um anyway
i fell in love with this [ __ ] truck
i'm a ford guy
i want to get a ford f-250 regular cab
[ __ ] the extra cab [ __ ] the crew cab
i'm a loner and plus i just like a
regular cab anyway
you know one of the best trucks i saw
over the last few years was that dodge
hemi one
that was the [ __ ] had the short bed
with just the regular cab
that [ __ ] truck is the [ __ ] so my
latest one that i love
i love the ford f-250 regular cab
with the turbo diesel four-wheel drive
in velocity blue go build that on the
ford website and tell me
that that isn't a [ __ ] gorgeous
goddamn truck but evidently it does
so bad in gas they don't even tell it's
not even an issue
it's not even an issue and i actually
for two days talked to my wife said i'm
gonna trade in
my four-door sedan for one of those
[ __ ] things and she goes it's stupid
you already have a truck i'm like it is
not stupid
i always end up feeling like mark
wahlberg's character
in boogie nights when she's tearing down
all the posters whenever i asked my wife
for something
why would you do that stop it
i want an f-250 i know i don't know how
to fix
things why can't i ever
listen i know it would chow gas and
either be no place to park it out here
but in between those moments i would
have a [ __ ]
euphoric ear-to-ear grin driving that
gorgeous gorgeous truck down the [ __ ]
street i'd keep it all stock
i wouldn't put stupid tires and rims on
it i keep it all stuck because i know
i know what i know i know what i like
i know what i got huey lewis on the
brain here man
oh bill burr hip to be square [ __ ]
stone sober
um that's what i am stone sober i'm not
straight edge i'm too old to be straight
edge i'm [ __ ] sober
all right straight edge is like you know
that's for young people young people are
straight edge right
your [ __ ] crotch is still talking to
me okay mine got disconnected a long
[ __ ] time ago my brain and my i don't
give a [ __ ] about anything right now
so um
anyway yeah the gas combustion engine is
going
[ __ ] bye-bye and it's not gonna go
quietly
as you hear all of these [ __ ] idiots
out there with those
[ __ ] mediocre speed cars with the
extra loud exhaust
going down the [ __ ] street not going
anywhere
no impressive speed whatsoever this is
how i know the gas combustion if and if
but
this is also me like
still having hope for humanity
because we already got it wrong the
first time because they had electric
cars 100 [ __ ] years ago
right and rather than pursuing that you
know
they electrocuted an elephant or
something like that and said electricity
was dangerous not that it wasn't
powerful it was dangerous
so they electrocuted a [ __ ] elephant
and everybody got into this stupid
you know the oil oil cuts the same
[ __ ] guys you know dictating our
foreign policy
according to my internet conspiracy
right um
anyway there's there's a video you've
got to see it's a tesla
model x versus an alpha romeo 4c
and i'm going to give you the spoiler
alert so shut it off right now if you
don't want to know
the tesla beats the alfa romeo 4c
while pulling a trailer with an alfa
romeo
romeo 4c on the [ __ ] trailer
all right it's [ __ ] it's a wrap
it's a [ __ ] rap and what i love
is it's quiet when it does it which
takes me to dave chappelle and my
favorite special
name killing them softly
right because there was a time when that
special came out
that there was a lot of loud
sort of like these slow slower cars with
the louder exhaust
acting like they were faster than they
were and then dave chappelle came in
like a [ __ ] tesla
right up to the microphone and [ __ ]
did like the best hour anybody had seen
i don't know
you know there were some great ones back
then but like that it was you know it
was the
easily the best one in five seven years
um
so anyway all of that [ __ ] so that got
me thinking like you know if i buy this
ford f250 regular cab turbo diesel 4x4
with in velocity blue
um with the turbo diesel and all that
and i kept it all
stock with the factory rims and tires
that in 20 years and i and i [ __ ]
babied that thing
and i kept it [ __ ] sweet i kept it
cherry
i kept it [ __ ] mint dude um
if i ever wanted to turn around and sell
it you know i could get like a lot of
money there's like certain cars that you
like
keep for life you know back in the day
there was these uh
these oldest successful guys they buy a
mercedes benz
and when you bought the top of the line
mercedes-benz it was built
so well that you you could just drive it
for the rest of your life and they would
meticulously maintain them
and back in the day i see the guys would
show up they used to have like badges on
the grills
for like going over like a hundred
thousand miles 200 000 miles back when
there was pride
you didn't build something to be
disposable right it was [ __ ] you know
cars back then were like they were
[ __ ]
it was like building a dynasty like you
were just gonna keep going
and keep [ __ ] winning now
everything's built like the florida
marlins right let's get a [ __ ]
championship it's [ __ ] great and then
the next
over the next summer they just [ __ ]
just shits to bed right
so um anyway
i i love that truck
and my wife just keeps telling me that
it's stupid
you know and in defense of her it is
stupid
okay but just because something's stupid
doesn't mean it's not awesome right
look at all of pop music all the pop
music if you listen to the lyrics
99 of it is [ __ ] stupid but it's
awesome
makes you smile you can sing you know
you're singing along to you know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about but it's
fun
so anyway um
i don't know i get i get like i fall in
love with cars and i can't stop and i
won't stop thinking about it but like
the the true test jesus christ i just
[ __ ] ate
stomach is growling like you can't
believe you know why because when i got
my fingers stitched up
they weighed me in my clothes and then
they told me i had a i had a a
bmi body mass index of 27 point
something i'm like what the [ __ ]
i used to be like a 13 or a 15 or an 18
so i know i was in i was in the [ __ ]
teens
so i looked it up i said it was a bmi a
bad and they said it said uh
26 to 27 is 20 generally speaking
because it also depends on
i don't know what it depends i know what
the [ __ ] it depends on is
20 overweight
and 30 being obese which i don't know
because
i know i got i got you know i got i got
to cut billy i'm not gonna lie to you i
look like i dropped a kid like a few
months ago
you know and immediately started doing
like going to the gym
so um i think what happened was i was
[ __ ] i started doing that veggie diet
and i didn't have enough protein i
didn't know which plants to eat
you know um like i just found out
radishes have like a
ton of iron in them so that's why i got
my mandolin and [ __ ] slice my goddamn
finger [ __ ]
trying to eat more of that [ __ ] but uh
you know i still eat i eat meat like
[ __ ] once a day or whatever right
so i think i just got like all fleshy
you know i wasn't feeding the muscles so
then the body burned those off and all i
was left was a big sack of fat
that's what the [ __ ] i am right now
you could [ __ ] refry some beans in a
pan if i was sitting in it
um anyway i got to uh [ __ ] lard
so i gotta [ __ ] get my [ __ ] together
here i wanna get back
down i gotta get back down leaning me
but i'm also
what was good is i dropped six pounds
you know probably five pounds of muscle
evidently uh over the last month
and uh
you know i just whatever the gyms are
[ __ ] open and back up again i just
got to get back on an elliptical when i
get an elliptical i'm fine
cardio burns fat right no it does fun my
body i have the flattest [ __ ] stomach
if i get on that [ __ ] if i start
getting some road gigs and i can [ __ ]
hit that thing because i have not been
on an elliptical
since uh i don't know february or last
[ __ ] year so
i really have no excuse i could always i
could still go for a walk or whatever
um so anyway so that's my latest one i
was i was in love with the 67 cadillac
el dorado
i was in love with the [ __ ] 65 ford
galaxy and wimbledon white with the blue
interior
and [ __ ] a hearse shifter with that
white knob i was in love with the
65 blue buick riviera
um i was in love with the [ __ ]
a bullnose shortbed f-150 xlt
um all of them
all right but this one might [ __ ]
stick
because what i love about this is it's
been a long time since i've been in love
with something that's like
brand [ __ ] new and um
it's the only thing i hate about this
business is where it is
you know is if i lived in the middle of
nowhere and there was like country roads
and that type of [ __ ]
i could drive that truck all over the
place but the problem is
is then i would have to deal with those
people's world view
i don't mind the music i don't mind the
food i don't mind the people it's just
when they start talking about the world
you're just looking at them like buddy
you got to get out you got to venture
past the swamp
their [ __ ] world view is and i'm not
just blaming people in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere because that isn't that
isn't uh
terrible because i'll tell you what's
[ __ ] hilarious is
um other than my own ignorance okay
which
i openly admit to um
is what drives me nuts oh i'm getting
what was driving me nuts when i woke up
this morning but i do but
is i am so sick of people posting [ __ ]
on [ __ ] social media posting life
advice
that is literally common sense
and they're presenting it like you first
of all you didn't know it and they just
cracked
some [ __ ] code and then all of these
[ __ ] people
like the emoji clapping preach
and what i'm really starting to think i
really think that 90
of the internet it's like grad school
for [ __ ] morons
and there's literally like morons
teaching
morons and all they got to do is
dazzle a crowd of morons listen listen
to this
[ __ ] [ __ ] here let me let me wait let
me let me
i gotta make sure i get this listen
listen to how [ __ ]
basic this is anybody who believes lies
about you before even hearing your side
of the story
was already looking for a way to be
against you
do i need to say that one more time do
you need to say it one month you didn't
even need to say it
that's my favorite part the arrogance in
the end
do i need to say that one more time like
you just
blew my [ __ ] mind
wait a minute so if someone
believes [ __ ] about me without even
talking to me first
that means they reject me oh
i thought that meant they were my best
friend
wow thank god
thank god
they're my favorite thing ever do i need
to say that again
[Laughter]
oh my god
she did everything but jump up on the
counter and do the lebron thing with the
baby powder after afterwards it's like
did did albert einstein
say that after he would present one of
his [ __ ] theories
e equals m c squared
do i need to say that again well yeah
actually you do and it'd be nice if you
told me what all those letters mean
because that i do not understand okay
you could tell albert einstein was smart
by the way he dressed
he didn't have time for fashion all
right the guy was so smart he had no
time for fashion he
he like putting on clothes was a f
picking out clothes was a waste of
[ __ ] time
i mean that right there that right there
as someone who's looking at a ford f-250
regular cab turbo diesel 4x4 velocity
blue
who's looking at that
who only owns a [ __ ] tack hammer is
gonna buy that beast of a truck
oh [ __ ] would i love that truck oh jesus
that's the reality you know what is i
think these people that post on
these social media things where they
they they say really obvious things
i think i i have such a reaction to it
because it just it reminds me of how
[ __ ] stupid i am
right and then i'm listening to that
it's just like oh my god that's me
that is i do that i do that with my [ __ ]
jokes
oh my god i'm gonna do i got a couple
shows tonight i'm gonna do a [ __ ] joke
tonight and then i'm just gonna [ __ ]
ask the crowd do i
do i need to say that again
um i don't know what you know what
i think everybody's just crawling out of
their childhood and then when they kind
of finally after years of being abused
with bad you know and then going out
into the world and then
i'm not going to live my life the way i
grew up and then you just pick [ __ ]
abusive people
i think when you finally wake up to the
fact that you did that
you're just excited and you want to
share the information that's probably
what it is if i can you know bill you're
going to do yoga are you going to apply
it all right so i apologize to that
woman
maybe there was some people out there
that needed to hear that
do i need to say that again
do i need to say that again it's got to
be jesus i mean i'll tell you right i
don't know what jesus is waiting for
like how much more can we get [ __ ] up
our own asses down here before he
finally decides that he's gonna grace us
with his [ __ ] another appearance
[ __ ] trashing everybody right ah [ __ ]
i got somebody coming out to the show
tonight i just remembered i gotta
[ __ ] put him down on a guest list
god damn it god damn it
um how about how about your boston
bruins
[Music]
uh splitting great weekend of hockey
with the uh pittsburgh penguins i got to
see some of it i did a lot of stuff with
the uh with the kids
as always they're taking up more and
more of my weekend and i am not
complaining at all um
there we go right here we go
here we go i found the person that i'm
supposed to text
okay
there we go typing with one thumb
sending because if i don't do it now i
will forget
question marks and all right um
anyway all right uh what the [ __ ] was i
talking about how dumb i
am no i was talking about the bruins
bruins went seven to five no defense in
that game
12 goals scored in three periods split
the weekend series brad marchand with
the [ __ ] hat trick baby
um crazy scoring that's always a great
thing to see that guy one of the most
selfless
um hockey players ever
always looking he that guy that guy
wants assists
like nobody's business had a night i
believe it was a one-timer
um and then also you know i missed the
moto gp race because i went out
for an easter brunch and you know the
deal you put on a suit you wear a pink
shirt because it's easter
right you get a little little [ __ ]
fruity with it right you go out there do
your thing
and uh went out to brunch there's never
anything healthy at brunch you know you
try
you try to eat some salad or [ __ ]
some sort of something it's just you
know
so i got that [ __ ] going on you know
i don't know i'm actually happy with
kind of with what i'm doing right now
all right the fact that i am not doing
anything
bad to myself and i'm still sort of
dropping weight
i just didn't need that bmi [ __ ]
smashing me in the face
[ __ ] [ __ ] i got i gotta [ __ ] start
i gotta start going on my old man walks
people like i'm gonna just i'm just
gonna buy a sweater and i gotta buy like
some of those big white sneakers that
old [ __ ] people wear right with the
[ __ ]
velcro straps across them
just go for a walk i always love seeing
old couples like that you ever see the
old ones that are still holding hams or
they're still arming arm
granted they might be just holding each
other up but i like to think it's still
look at them look at them they made it
they raised their kids you know
i wonder what conversations are like
when you get to be that old with
somebody
you know she just wakes up hey i was
thinking and going over to
over the shellies
and getting uh getting an iceberg wedge
would you like to do that with me this
thing you're just looking at i'm like
well yeah i mean we could be [ __ ]
dead tomorrow
and then i never have an iceberg wedge
again let's go
just get in the car and you [ __ ] go
every day thinking that [ __ ] uh you know
i follow sammy haga
on [ __ ] uh instagram and he was
interviewing his neighbor
who turned 100 years old the guy still
has you know
has a drink seemed you know he had a
[ __ ] martini
he doesn't booze though he was just
talking about
you know clean living made me feel good
you know but i can kind of continue
doing this [ __ ]
um i'm getting to the point though it's
it's kind of cool like i don't
[ __ ] miss it as bad at night
like i i definitely get a little [ __ ]
edgy around nine if i don't have any
shows
and i start bouncing off the walls and i
start coming at my wife and i can feel
her being like listen
i'm not the one who said you had to stop
drinking you decided so don't be [ __ ]
coming at me she always gives me that
look and i'm like all right you're right
you're right and um oh dude you know
what i did i [ __ ] blew it with easter
i went out and i got the [ __ ] candy
and i did all of that
and i laid out all the you know my wife
does
they did easter differently so she's not
into coloring eggs which next year i'm
doing it
you know i get it who wants to have 50
[ __ ] hard-boiled eggs sitting around
you know when you've got two kids who
don't want to eat them
so she has these plastic eggs right so
we just put the candy in there
and i was like upset with her because it
was the night before and she hadn't
gotten the candy and she's really not
doing anything because easter wasn't a
big deal
this is like something you deal with
when you're married like something's a
big deal to you but it's not a big deal
to the other person
you can't get upset with the other
person if you're an adult which i'm not
because they didn't do it because they
don't know so oh my god so i [ __ ] go
out and i get the candy
i put the candy in each one of the
little [ __ ] eggs
all right and then i just put my
daughter to bed and a lot of times she
gets up
she comes walking you know across the
hall into our room or whatever you know
and i'm like well i can't start hiding
the things until she goes to sleep
so um
i don't know i i [ __ ] fell asleep and
my wife fell asleep
and then when my daughter woke up and
came into the room i forgot that it was
easter
and she went downstairs and all the eggs
with the candy were just sitting there
on the counter
like the easter bunny was late he just
said here you [ __ ] hide him
and she still was excited and all that
so i had to play it off
like ah we're the easter bunny drop them
all off
[Laughter]
at least i had the brains
to hide the bags of candy after i did it
you know because my daughter's really
smart and she'd [ __ ]
would have put two and two together and
then i gotta be honest with you wouldn't
that have been better
rather than start this [ __ ] lie i
don't understand this whole [ __ ]
oh what a tango web we weave when first
we practice to deceive
and then one of the first things you do
is you tell like that that [ __ ]
you know the the lsd lie
of tooth fairies and rabbits and santa
claus and all of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
um and don't even tell me that you know
i ruined it for your kid because if you
listen to this [ __ ] podcast with your
kid you already ruined your kid all
right
um anyway yeah so i [ __ ] blew it and
then i was upset
i was really upset with myself and then
my wife didn't think it was that big a
deal
which then upset me that she didn't mean
it's not how come you know
i even text her i said you come upstairs
and you come downstairs you [ __ ]
hide the [ __ ] candy
whatever i'm sure it's my [ __ ] fault
somewhere along the line anyway
um all right let's uh
let's get into some of the reads here
for the week i have i also have to make
sure that
everything came in because i know i have
like tour dates here
fall tour dates everybody can you can do
you
believe it um let's see what we
got here
uh please announce new tour dates on
billboard.com
well where the [ __ ] are they i gotta
click on my own goddamn what's good i
click on my website
i get a hit right we got a hit people
are still going to the website
billboard.com
look at that ugly bastard tour dates
okay here we go
um tour dates
clicking on them clicking on the tour
dates
where are they where are they they are
not here
what the [ __ ] god damn it
why don't you just send me the [ __ ]
tour dates
ugh you know somebody the other day
asked me to can you do my [ __ ] roast
i go when is it and where is it and they
send me a [ __ ] link
i click on the link and it's the
advertisement for the show and [ __ ] me
if i can figure out when it is and where
it is
so i finally write back to the guy say
listen i'm too [ __ ] old for a link
just tell me what it is
the tour de uh jesus christ says the
tortilla
hang on a second the tour dates are not
up on my website period can you just
send me the tour dates
period text them to me
question mark you like when i was
thinking about what i was going to say
to my two or dates it still got tor i
thought i was gonna write tortilla again
all right new please announce new tour
dates are up on billboard.com we're not
as of me [ __ ] clicking this but they
will be
oh they will be guys can you tell them
about doing yoga
i don't want you know what's great now
now when i get mad i'm already thinking
i don't want to be this mad i still get
that mad but
it it it's a step that i've taken
um oh by the way i missed the moto gp
race
because i was doing all the easter stuff
screwing it up
but um
what was i gonna say uh a buddy of mine
that watches motogp just
wrote to me in all capital letters best
[ __ ] sport out there what a [ __ ]
race
so i guess it's an instant classic and
i'm extending an olive branch to old
school nba fans
that are sick of watching super teams
and they miss watching competition
uh motogp is not a big time commitment
you know you can you can sign up on a
moto gp.com you click
click on calendar create you know create
an account sign up
click on the calendar section and just
watch
uh just it's just
it's [ __ ] amazing it's guys on
motorcycles going over 200 miles an hour
passing each other it's [ __ ] insane
it's [ __ ] insane or don't or don't
whatever all right i'm just a dumb guy
that wants a ford f250 regular cab turbo
diesel 4x4 and velocity blue
i'm really hoping that i i i've told
enough [ __ ] jokes in my life for
somebody
at the ford motor company
to just get the ball rolling on this all
right to give me some sort of [ __ ]
podcast discount
i'll still pay 95 percent of sticker i
don't give a [ __ ] just give me a
discount
something that i can say to my give me
give me a reason
to buy that [ __ ] thing and i will um
all right let's get to the uh let's get
to the advertising here for this week
all right uh by the way people at ford
motor company
do i need to say that again huh
you want to sell one of those [ __ ]
things okay take a little cream off the
top
that's all that's all that's all i need
and i can sell this to my wife
all right policy genius everybody you
know april means a lot of not so fun
things
getting fooled getting rained on
and getting your taxes done well don't
forget about the [ __ ] easter bunny
the way i did
um oh [ __ ] did i just send the wrong
text message to somebody
ah [ __ ] oh jesus
i did i sent the [ __ ] text message to
the wrong person
you know what's great about you guys
listening to my text you get to see how
[ __ ] stupid i
am copy
okay here we go
paste try it again paste
boom there we go all right
so if you need a positive experience to
balance it all out consider
shopping for home and amp
what is amp auto insurance with policy
genius
home insurance auto insurance what is
that for guitar players amp what would
that be
amplifier amphibian
i don't know policy genius can help you
find home
and amp auto
all right [ __ ] this let me look this
[ __ ] up tell you i'm having a [ __ ]
day
amp insurance
what does that mean amp insurance is an
independent insurance why not it's not
what this is an insurance company
amp insurance abbreviation
abbreviation or acronym amp average
manufacturer price
all right i give up i don't know what it
means i don't know what it means i'm
sure you guys know what it means you're
[ __ ] laughing at me right now
home and amp auto insurance similar i
would think
life insurance uh similar to what you
have now but at a lower whatever if you
got you have [ __ ] insurance
you want to be paying less you got to
use policy genius because they'll st
you just put in what you're paying and
then they'll go out there check
all the [ __ ] insurance companies and
try to make sure that uh
that they're beating it okay in fact
they save customers up to 1055
per year by re-shopping their home and
amp auto coverage getting
started is easy first head to
policygenius.com and answer a few quick
questions about yourself and your
property
then policy genius takes it from there
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive
to all-state to find your lowest quotes
the policy genius
uh team will look all at all the ways to
maximize your savings including bundling
your home in auto policies
i guess it's just home and auto
insurance i'm going to say the rest of
that's just a typo
if policy genius finds a better rate
than what you're paying now they'll
switch you over for
free um that kind of service has earned
policy genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviewers on trustpilot and
google
policy genius can promise that you won't
leave their website feeling like a fool
they've saved customers up to one
thousand
fifty-five dollars per year compared to
their current home and auto policies
head over to policygenius.com to get
started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's right it's nice to get it right
all right simply safe everybody isn't
that how we all want to feel
if you have 30 free minutes you never
have to worry about a break-in
at home ever again this is how quick and
easy it is to set up a security system
from simply safe
it's the kind of thing that is so easy
that you can do it during a netflix
binge
watching the game or listening to a
certain podcast i think they're talking
about this one
simply safe is incredibly easy to
customize for your home just go to
simply safe
sim
it used to be so hard to spel dot-com
uh you can easily choose the exact
sensors you need
or get help from one
of their experts i love the exact senses
what if you have a [ __ ] pervert
running up to your window with this dick
out
you should have some sort of [ __ ]
sensor that then just sprays out like
lava
it [ __ ] uh at junk level uh
i'll get it'll get to your house in
about a week which means by
this time next week you and your whole
family can go to bed knowing your home
is being guarded it's easy to assume
everyone in your house already feels
safe but they might
not and it's not worthwhile to talk
about it and it's ill
and it's sorry and it's worthwhile to
talk about it i was gonna say it didn't
make sense
and simply safe is a small easy step to
make sure
everyone feels safe at home go to simply
safe s-i-m-p-l-i
dot com slash bird today to customize
your system
and get a free security camera
all right oh look who it is everybody oh
one of my favorites old zip
you know if you're a business owner
who's hiring you've probably faced a lot
of challenges when it comes to finding
the right person for your role
that's why hiring can feel like trying
to find a needle in a haystack
sure
[Music]
you can post your job to some job board
but then all you can do is hope the
right person comes along
which is why yeah they think that's how
they posted for the monkeys
casting the monkeys and charles manson
auditioned to be the drummer
okay you don't want to do it that way
this is why you should try ziprecruiter
for free
at ziprecruiter.com you post the job on
zip
uh it gets sent out to over 100 top job
sites with one click
then zip recruiters matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job and act
and activity uh invites them to apply
in fact zip is so effective that four
out of five
employ four to five employers who post
on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day come on people time is money
you don't need the next charles manson
showing up saying that he knows how to
[ __ ] you know
put together a home equity mortgage all
right you want the right person you want
a peter tork vibe
rest his soul it's no wonder over 2.3
million
businesses have come over to zip
for their hiring needs so firing needs
so while other companies
overwhelm you with a way with way too
many options zip recruiter finds a way
to find what you're looking for the
needle in the haystack and right now you
can try zip
uh for free at their website at this
website ziprecruiter.com once again
reminder
remember to go to this unique place
z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r
dot com slash burst spell out bur
b-u-r-r
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
all right oh lastly but not leastly the
original people that
advertised on my podcast i'm not talking
about herbs
hot cider which if you're looking to
booze it up around
the last couple of cold nights here as
we get into spring
you got to go to herbs herbs uh herb
cider.com
tim alexander for primus his delicious
hard cider
stamps.com everybody uh let's face it
taking trips to the post office is
probably not how you want to spend your
time
that's why i recommend making mailing
and shopping online
at stamps.com oh shipping online so say
what the [ __ ] is shopping
stamps.com allows you to mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your own
computer
send letters ship packages and pay a lot
less with discounted rates from the
united states postal service
and the united parcel service usps and
ups
for you regular people and more
stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money you
know what that reminds me of
i actually looked up tooth and nail i
thought about that the other day ain't
gonna fight tooth and nail i used to
think
you have [ __ ] nail going into your
tooth it meant that you would bite and
scratch whatever you had to do to get
what the [ __ ] you wanted
never knew that still don't know what
amp
insurance is though um with stamps.com
you get the services of the post office
and the unups in all all in one place
plus big discounts of mail
on mailing and shipping rates you've
heard me talk about stamps.com they've
been sponsoring the show for over nine
years now
and if you haven't tried it what the
[ __ ] are you waiting for
stamps.com brings the services of the
united states postal service and ups
right to your own computer you've said
this 10 times
stamps.com is a must-have for any
business whether you're a small
office sending out invoices an online
seller
shipping out orders or even a giant
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
with stamps.com
you get discounts of up to 40 off uh
post office rates and up to 62 percent
off ups
uh shipping rates not to mention
stamps.com is a fraction of the cost
of those expensive postage meters stop
wasting time
um time to go to the post stop wasting
time going to the [ __ ] post office
sorry and go just
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk
and with my promo code burr you get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur that's
stamps.com
promo code bar b-u-r-r
thank christ i got through that
all right well let's get into maybe some
of your questions here
for the week everybody um
you know some of you who were uh maybe
uh
didn't listen last time i got three
stitches in my finger
because i i bought one of those
mandolins which are [ __ ] great
but just pay attention when you go to
wash the thing and somebody here is to
help me out oh wait did i just get my
tour dates did i just get my tour dates
oh my god i'm so [ __ ] excited
it has been so long since i went to a
theater and spewed my ignorance all over
people holy
[ __ ] okay buckle up date
venue city state here we go friday
july 22nd 2021 i'm going to be in las
vegas viva
las vegas las vegas
nevada at the cosmopolitan
of las vegas hang on a second hang on
one [ __ ] second
one [ __ ] second let's we're gonna do
this right
we are gonna do i'm gonna have some
background music when i
[ __ ] when i [ __ ] play this [ __ ]
here
let me see here come on
come on please be give me a video give
me a video
here we go is this it is going to play
it
why won't you play it oh oh is that what
it is you know i'm going to hit pause
i'm going to do this right i'm actually
a little production value here we go
all right [ __ ] that i was going to try
to go find the record but i i i got my
record stacked up
i i gotta i'm not i don't want [ __ ]
time all right but i still gonna do it
right here okay i actually
you know i'm gonna take this podcast to
the next [ __ ] level
can i ever type in the password
correctly here we go here we go the
right music here we go
all right
[Music]
where am i july 3rd
july 2nd and 3rd las vegas at the
cosmopolitan
in las vegas nevada august 28th
i'll be at the seminole hard rock cafe
in hollywood florida
where else september 3rd atlantic city
i'm hitting all the dirtbags sell the
casino towns i love it
september 3rd at the hard rock live
and september 4th where next
[Music]
pace d [ __ ] thighs september 5th
sunday
i'll be in beth bethlehem pennsylvania
oh jesus at the wing
wind creek event center
[Music]
and then i'm gonna be in kansas city
missouri a few barbecue eating
[ __ ]
at the uh the starlight
all these dates will be up on the
website by the way oh then look at this
one you got to go to this one man
i'm gonna be at red rocks amphitheater
that's right
this strippers dream came true denver
colorado on thursday september 30th
i hope i got these right no that might
be september 16th
yeah september 16th sorry all these
dates will be right [ __ ] it i'm just
gonna tell you where i'm gonna be
fox theater st louis missouri mystic
lake casino minneapolis
where else cobb energy center performing
arts [ __ ] center
in atlanta georgia
suck my dick coca-cola roxy atlanta
georgia
a couple of nights there the terrace
theater now that's where richard pryor
did his uh live on the sunset strip
one of the best special arguably the
best special of all time
and i lost all my dates where the [ __ ]
did they go did that make any sense
half of those the date of the i'm
playing all those venues but i think i
said the date's wrong
knowing me knowing me got a few more
terrace theater in long beach
october 21st i think or november 5th i
don't know
uh wait it says it up here how it goes
date
venue city all right so the date is
first
jesus christ just go to the website
people i don't know what the [ __ ] to
tell you
where else will i be oh one of my
favorite towns i'll be in reno
the grand resort sierra resort casino
that's in november san jose in november
the center for performing arts
the fox theater in detroit michigan
chris cornell's last gig i believe was
there rest his soul
um
harrah's resort southern california
that's valley center
that thing's been rescheduled since
[ __ ] right before the pandemic
uh indianapolis why are you going to
indianapolis bill the murad theater at
old national center
uh three nights there wow
and then i got uh in arizona i'm at the
arizona federal theater
oh it's gonna be great i cannot [ __ ]
wait
cannot [ __ ] wait
that's something oh that's nice [ __ ]
right there
oh i forgot to tell them not to book me
through i'm gonna tell them about no
more
dates in december i like the [ __ ]
holidays
evidently i don't like easter
considering i forgot to [ __ ] hide the
eggs
gee the [ __ ] eggs i mean what is that
about man jesus
it's just it's just all over the map a
bunny i know
people have done bits about this but
[ __ ] you don't realize how nuts it is
until you actually try to pull it off
all right mandolin oh so now you're
gonna blame blame a [ __ ] bunny that
that lays eggs because you fell asleep
built you're right
you're right still a great holiday it's
a good story what are you gonna do
all right mandolin gloves hey billy nine
fingers
uh google no cry
cut resistant gloves you can find them
on amazon for around ten dollars they're
basically kevlar gloves
and made to stop exactly what happened
to you
you use them with sharp knives while
grating foods
shucking oyster woodworking you name it
they're food safe and machine washable i
have a pair and i don't mandolin without
him
dude god bless you
god bless you no cut
no cry cut resistant gloves i'm googling
those right now no
cry cut resistant gloves
oh look at them they're kind of stylish
too
holy [ __ ] they also look a little
murderous so if you have a bad
relationship with your wife i i
i wouldn't put these on like she might
grab a pistol or something like i'm just
just cutting some radishes
all right fat jokes
um
okay fat jokes oh jesus bill you seem to
spend a lot of time telling fat jokes
no i think you just focus on the fact
that i i tell a lot of jokes
tell a whole bunch of jokes i talk about
conspiracy i make fun of banks oil
company i make fun of [ __ ] apple
i make fun of uh [ __ ] people on
bicycles
i make fun of people that [ __ ]
uh post [ __ ] on instagram and act like
it's deep when it isn't
i make fun of people who don't have a
fast car but have a loud exhaust
uh what else i make fun of people who
don't wear masks or listen to doctors
i make fun of myself i make fun of my
wife i trash women
i make fun of cats i make fun of the nba
i mean there's a whole bunch of things
but let me guess you're a fat [ __ ] so
now you're gonna take this personally
okay here we go
bill you seem to spend a lot of time
telling fat jokes i think at this point
we all understand that you have no
respect for fat people and have even
have contempt for them you see how they
did she drag or he dragged you all
uh this aspect of your brand
air quote is tiresome and shows a lack
of creativity
i hope you move on with your life and
create some new actual
funny material beyond verbally attacking
other human beings
and what other human beings did you
stick up for you fat [ __ ] you only
talked about yourself go eat some more
cookies you [ __ ]
um i hate cell you know you know
actually that's kind of funny a
self-serving fat person
that's the problem um anyway
if you had those t-rex arms uh no
dude [ __ ] you that that you look at all
the goddamn ginger jokes that are out
there there's literally kick a ginger
date there's not a roller fat guy down
the hill day is there
go [ __ ] yourself i'm orange
i have no sympathy for you i make fun of
everything that's what the [ __ ] i'm
supposed to do
all right so get out of your fields and
get over it with a nice big [ __ ]
gallon of ice cream
um vietnam helicopter pilot uh hey bill
thought you would like
the helicopter stories from vietnam huey
pilot colonel matt jackson on the jocko
podcast episode 275 oh my god i would
love to listen to that
hat in hand um the whole podcast is
interesting
but they for a while uh i think you
meant to say talk about all different
kinds of auto rotations and cool
helicopter
stuff around the 45 minute mark
seems like something you would be into
enjoy and go [ __ ] yourself p.s
your father all right cool oh awesome
all right beautiful beautiful beautiful
all right here we go
what is the name of that i thought you
enjoyed the helicopter stories from matt
i think would have been nice oh the
jocko podcast
275 colonel
oh yeah there we go the relentless
danger
from the air in vietnam with huey pilot
colonel matt jackson
dude the [ __ ] and they were kids when
they did it
the balls that they had the [ __ ]
balls
i could i get nervous if there's a
crosswind
tailwind or whatever all right woman
president
billy boy i am a fan of kenya
and i am a fan of the podcast are you
from kenya
oh you are from kenya that's awesome
being from kenya there is
a country to the south of us called
tanzania
the country's president has recently
died and by law the vice president takes
over
and she's a lady
[Music]
pause giving you a moment to freak out i
don't give a [ __ ]
there should be there should be just as
many women as this guy ideally that's
that's what the [ __ ] they should be and
just i just don't want to listen to the
rhetoric
that uh there'll be less war because
women are somehow nicer than men they're
not
they're not it's just men have been
oppressing them so they
feel bad but rather than giving them
equal pay
they just throw a bunch of compliments
at them
you're strong you're brave you're
smarter if you ran the world there'd be
no war they're just filibustering
because they don't want to give up their
corner office but it's it's all a bunch
of [ __ ] women are just like men
okay it's very difficult to find a good
one um
after seeing this whole thing unravel i
remembered your your old bit
of if a woman became the president we'll
have the first male first lady that's
right
and he's gone sit there
and do some first lady [ __ ] just thought
i could share the news with the podcast
i finished up
with the old podcast which are episodes
apps 2011 to 2021. i also found a
website which has
the the phone podcast
oh 2007 to 2010 which are [ __ ]
awesome especially those stories of
getting drunk during
nfl game also been listening to all your
appearances on opie and anthony jesus
christ
he went through my whole library and you
were all
into a lot of conspiracy stories yeah i
was i was i i
was really i was new to the internet
and that technology that wasn't actually
i wasn't i was probably on the internet
for 10 years i was just an idiot back
then
um and i imagine 10 years from now i'll
look back on me now
and think that i was a [ __ ] idiot you
know who knows i don't know
i mean isn't that part of life you look
back five years ago but i can't believe
i [ __ ] said that
i was an idiot right and which is why
going back in somebody's life to cancel
them
is [ __ ] stupid because most likely
the person you're cancelling doesn't
exist anymore
um am i going down the rabbit hole of
all the billboard stuff
love the comedy love the podcast and go
[ __ ] yourself um
that's pretty cool all the way over in
kenya well thank you for listening
um about the cardio doesn't burn fat guy
v shred yeah that guy's shredded hey
billion burr i heard you laughing at the
guy on the advertisement who repeats
over and over that cardio doesn't burn
fat
and thought it'd be relevant to tell you
that the guy has been a known fraud in
the fitness industry
really i mean he's he's shredded though
i mean he's doing something right isn't
he he prays on the uninformed public
hey by getting ads pushed on facebook
and youtube and
tries being a contrarian to the tried
and true
fitness advice of diet and exercise to
get money for his bogus overpriced
supplements and workout plans while
being funded and controlled
by marketing gurus who are out there to
make as much money as humanly possible
and not to try getting people in shape
oh well yeah
yeah i mean that's that's basically most
business models
i know you've pretty much called bs on
the guy but i just wanted to make sure
all of your listeners knew the full
story thanks and i love the podcast but
you didn't give any exam you just what
you just put
out there was accusations
uh
okay uh a youtuber josh brett made a
viral video that got the attention
from prominent fitness youtubers
exposing v shred for their shady
business model
oh here's the video link below all right
i'll give you the name of the video
you guys can make up your own mind
because i have no idea if this
if the guy is actually telling the truth
and this guy is his competitor and wants
to [ __ ]
um discredit him it said we need to stop
v shred let's see the comments
uh okay here's some of the comments i
can't seem to escape v
shreds ads on youtube that dude can talk
for 45 minutes about weight loss and
never tell you how to lose weight
um
i swear fitness community is becoming
more and more like the beauty community
drama
that's all fascinating um anyway
let's get back to it okay all right so
i'm sorry the name of it did i say the
name of the video
or did i not where the hell is it
it's uh we need to stop v shred
um all right girlfriend is too religious
hey billy [ __ ] nutbag uh my
name is carl i am a 27 year old guy
who is starting to become annoyed at my
girlfriend's religious behaviors
um it doesn't bother me so much that she
is
christian for i also believe in god
prayer and keeping true to a solid
traditional set of moral values
it's just that her life seems to revolve
around christianity and her church
her entire family is extremely christian
and all her friends are from the church
well jesus christ you didn't notice this
from the beginning
was she acting like she wasn't religious
i mean the last time she invited me to
hang out with them was to a bonfire at
the church where we were drinking
apple juice and listening to justin
bieber
oh boy well justin
i don't know well doesn't justin bieber
i always get him confused
justin timberlake was the first one
justin bieber
well doesn't he sing about banging
chicks
that's kind of weird isn't it i thought
he did at least when he was younger
now that he's old now but now he's you
know he's
wise beyond his years considering he
made it when he was like 14.
so you age and dog years as a [ __ ]
celebrity i would think um
anyway he goes don't get me wrong i
didn't want to date a crazy
a crazy party crazy party-going wench
i did want to date a nice morally
responsible girl who is fun to be with
just not with these powerful christian
undertones she even invited me to go to
the bar with her friends
the thursday before easter all right
she said she told me they were going to
honor the last supper by eating some
food and by drinking cocktails
i looked at her and i was just thinking
are you [ __ ] serious
i know she has her belief but is there a
good way of telling her to lighten up
at the very least not to call me out on
little stuff
like using the lord's name in vain that
actually pisses me off especially when
she
does it around others or give me these
long disappointed looks when my sense of
humor runs over the topic
of christianity um well
okay i'm gonna read the rest of this and
then i'll give you my opinion here
i like her a lot i'm just not sure if i
can handle that amount
of religious energy for the rest of my
life much less
have her turn my kids into nutless
christian geeks who go to youth groups
every other night
oh and how do i convince her that she is
an adult she drives home at 12 at night
because she feels that sleeping
over might be disrespectful to her
parents and unchristian like even though
she will let me plow her
20 minutes before mass no joke uh
oh jesus
i've well so she's not all bad uh i i
told her that
it is a two-way street that you should
respect
her parents options but they should also
respect her ability to make her own
decisions
you know why they should because she is
almost [ __ ] 30.
oh please give
me your opinion on the situation love
you and good luck
making another child that is if nia is
willing
to ever couple with you again
um look
she needs to be dating one of those
people that goes to the bonfire and is
excited to be there
all right um i don't think it doesn't
sound
like i don't know how she started doing
the christian thing but you said you
you know you like her a lot do you love
her
do you love her you just have to decide
like
like you don't have to have any of this
conversation with this woman
unless you plan on marrying her um
and if you plan on marrying and then you
got to sit down just say listen
if you know i stub my toe i'm going to
say god damn it or jesus christ i
am and i don't need a [ __ ] lecture
from you all right
you can stop short of saying i don't
think jesus is coming back
you can stop short of that you don't
need to be a jerk you know
but like yeah she's gonna want her kids
to be super [ __ ] religious like her i
would think
so i would i would figure that out
but um
i i don't i don't think it's a bad thing
that somebody's that [ __ ] religious
anymore i just don't
if it works for them and they're not
hurting other people
you know if you know i don't know if i
was a better person i would actually go
to a church every week just for the
reminder to not be a complete piece of
[ __ ] i do like that aspect of it
i don't like the intolerance of it the
same way
i'm liberal but i can't listen to these
extreme liberal people who cancel people
for
for for having a a [ __ ] just a
thought that was different than theirs
so it's like most things you know it's a
group trying to do this for a good
reason and then it eventually spins out
of control
all right you're 27 years old you know
maybe you just want maybe just get out
of this thing
okay you don't seem i get me honest with
you i don't think you love this person
i think you've hung around with them
long enough that you have feelings for
them
but i don't think you love them at no
point did you even say that you like
this
love this person you just said you like
her a lot um but i really think
that you look look she's three years old
and then you
she's you know she's an animal in the
rack she's banging you and all this type
of [ __ ] right and you're having a good
you're having a good [ __ ] time
and now you're like okay what am i gonna
do here and she's like
[ __ ] the 700 club and you know
that's not where you're at so i i think
i would get out of this if i was
if i just you know and take this off
with a grain of salt because i don't
know you or what's going on but just the
way that was written
i just think you know you're having a
good time you guys are banging and
whatever but uh
now when you actually think about taking
the next step and getting a little more
serious with her
you're like jesus christ my kids are
gonna be like [ __ ]
reenacting the last supper and [ __ ]
instead of listening to ac dc that's not
what the [ __ ] i'm looking for
you know if i'm reading this wrong and
you actually really care about this
person you want to marry him then you
need to sit down and talk to him and
just say listen you just gotta lay it
out there
and just say listen i'm going to say
whatever i want i'm going to make jokes
about whatever i want
and sometimes i'm going to make fun of
christianity
and i'm not going to raise my kids uh
to be a bunch of church-going sissies
all right you're not turning them into
like they're not you know
my kid stubs his toe and goes oh what
the [ __ ] jesus christ you know
i understand watch the language but not
you know
that's out of respect for us it's not
not out of respect for this guy who said
he was coming back and he never did
okay cause at this point he's kind of
like the absentee father for everybody
isn't he
am i crazy you don't to go that far you
know what i mean um
yeah i would just say i would say that
and it'll make the breakup a lot easier
if you just if you just tell her like
yeah listen
i'm going to have kids you know but
they're not doing this jesus [ __ ]
so you can [ __ ] forget that you
forget that
all [ __ ] day long why can't i plug
this [ __ ] thing in
what the [ __ ] am i doing wrong
sorry as always i don't have any [ __ ]
time trying to do 50 things at once
that's what i do
all right you're 27 years old man you
know go on get a 25 year old who never
goes to church
and have a good time baby
do whatever the [ __ ] you want you know
or stick with this one but you got to
tell her what's up if you're going to
stick with her
that's it all right cause you know what
she's doing that for you she's letting
you know what's up
marry me have some christian kids and
stand around a bonfire
i see fine i see rain i've seen sunny
days that i thought would never end
but i always thought that i'd see jesus
once again you know
switching up the lyrics no i don't know
what they do i've never been to some
[ __ ] like that but i can tell you right
now
i would be like uh are they gonna
sacrifice a virgin like what the [ __ ] is
going on here
i need to get out of here you know
i don't know but i'm also an [ __ ] all
right that's it
i'm calling it right now the baylor
bears are gonna beat gonzaga
they're gonna beat him i think ucla
showed people how to beat him
right in the first half not the second
half i'd say in the first half i didn't
even watch the second half in the first
half you just [ __ ] slow it down they
they can't that they're the kansas city
chiefs
everybody's getting lulled into their
game start getting loved into their game
um i don't know [ __ ] all right
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves i'll check
in on you on thursday i have a huge
guest
a huge drummer guest on thursday i'm
teasing it all right who has a brand new
book out
that is so [ __ ] educational and
amazing i'm actually applying these
study practices
of it to trying to get my instrument
rating on my pilot license because it's
all the same [ __ ]
all right no not all the same [ __ ] it's
just so genius the way he wrote it all
right that's it i'll see you guys on
thursday